im Iran hört die brutale Gewalt nicht
auf mit äußerste Härte versucht die
iranische Regierung noch immer die
Proteste einzudämmen mehrere
Demonstranten sind zum Tode verurteilt
worden zwei bereits hingerichtet das
Brandenburger Tor hier bei uns vor zwei
Tagen beleuchtet mit dem iranischen
protestslogan Frau Leben Freiheit nicht
nur in Berlin gibt es
solidaritätsbekunde
aktuelle Bilder aus dem Iran aber zu
bekommen das ist kaum möglich derzeit in
der iranischen Hauptstadt Teheran aber
ist unser Kollege Jörg Brase schönen
guten Morgen was bekommen sie von den
Protesten mit lassen sich die Menschen
einschüchtern oder gehen Sie weiter auf
die Straße
also unser Eindruck ist dass es nicht
mehr so große Protestmärsche gibt wie
wir sie noch vor zehn Tagen gesehen
haben das mag auch damit zusammenhängen
vielleicht dass die Regierung die
Internetsperre weiter angezogen hat das
glaube ich aber nicht mein Eindruck ist
schon dass nach den Hinrichtungen oder
nach der ersten Hinrichtung vor gut
einer Woche die Verunsicherung und auch
die Angst in der Bevölkerung gestiegen
ist hier in Teheran das ist mein
Eindruck herrscht schon so etwas wie
gespenstische Ruhe das heißt jetzt nicht
das ist keine Protestaktion mehr gibt
die gibt es schon noch hier ein Teheran
auch in anderen Städten aber so wie es
aussieht auf etwas geringerem Niveau ist
sind vor allen Dingen Protestaktion
gegen Todesurteile und drohende
Hinrichtungen so sind gestern einige
Ärzte auf die Straße gegangen um gegen
die Hinrichtung eines ihrer Kollegen zu
protestieren es gibt da also durchaus
auch im Internet Solidaritätsaktionen
und zwei Hinrichtungen die eigentlich
vergessen und für heute morgen
angekündigt worden waren wurden dann von
den Gerichten kurzzeitig gestoppt ähm ob
das tatsächlich ein Zeichen ist dass die
Regierung einlenkt vielleicht auch wenn
man das Gefühl hat dass die
Einschüchterung durch die ersten beiden
Hinrichtungen schon dass dieses Ziel
erreicht wurde das kann man im Moment
noch nicht sagen die EU hat ja auch neue
Sanktionen gegen Iran verhängt die
Vereinten Nationen haben den Iran aus
der UN frauenrechtskommission
rausgeworfen inwieweit kann das denn die
Führung im Iran zu einem ja anderen
Vorgehen bewegen
schwer zu sagen die Regierung steht
natürlich unter Druck und reagiert dann
auf diese Strafmaßnahmen dann auch mit
harschen Protesten droht mit
Gegenmaßnahmen aber offensichtlich gibt
es auch
kompromissangebote in dem Zusammenhang
muss man glaube ich sehen dass eine
Delegation der internationalen Atome
Energie Behörde in den nächsten Tagen
hier in Teheran sein wird wir das Land
besuchen wird man will offensichtlich
erreichen dass die in Stocken geraten im
Gespräch wieder aufgenommen werden dass
ein Kompromiss gibt dass das Abkommen
wieder eingesetzt wird in im Zuge dessen
müssten dann einige wirtschaftsaktionen
aufgehoben werden Iran will wieder sein
Öl verkaufen Iran braucht das Geld denn
seit Beginn der Proteste ist die
iranische Währung immer wieder auf neue
Rekord Tiefstände gefallen so wurde
gestern auch der viel zu Chef der
Zentralbank gefeiert weil sie es nicht
geschafft hat diesen Trend äh umzukehren
und man fürchtet natürlich das damit
dann auch die Inflation steigt dass die
Preise steigen und damit dann auch das
Wut und das Protestpotential in der
Bevölkerung Einschätzung von japhase
vielen Dank